BRADY HARAN: So here's a video
a lot of you specifically
asked me to make.
First of all, here's
the background.
A few weeks ago, I made this
video with my neighbors, Danny
and Emily, all about numbers
in a tin of spaghetti.
At the end of the video, I
offered them 4 pounds each.
This is what 4 pounds
looks like.
Or I offered to put this piece
of paper on eBay and give the
proceeds to them.
DANNY: I reckon eBay.
EMILY: We should go for eBay?
DANNY: Yeah.
EMILY: OK, yeah.
BRADY HARAN: And the winning
bid, which came from this chap
in Australia, was--
well, somewhat more than
4 pounds each.
Now, those of you who followed
the auction desperately wanted
to see the reaction when
the kids got the money.
So this is what 550 pounds looks
like in one-pound coins.
EBay obviously have taken
their share of things.
And here is that reaction
you wanted to see.
BRADY HARAN: They're all
one-pound coins.
BRADY HARAN: I don't know.
How much do you think
is there?
BRADY HARAN: That's all yours.
So what would you do if you were
10 and 13 years old and
got given all that money?
Have a think about it.
DANNY: Thanks for that.
EMILY: Thank you.
BRADY HARAN: I've actually got
a note here from Danny and
Emily, who have thought
about it.
And this is what they
spent it on--
a couple of treats for
themselves; a present for
their sister, who wasn't able to
be involved in the filming;
taking the whole family,
including their mom and dad,
out for a family meal; and
sponsoring a toilet in a third
world country through
this scheme.
So they're giving a fair
portion of what
they made to charity.
And that's not where the
story ends, actually.
The people from Heinz, who make
the Numberetti, they were
fascinated by the video.
They actually sent a couple
of gift packs to the kids.
But they also sent all these
tins of baked beans.
Danny and Emily's father
actually works for a local
charity here in Nottingham
helping people in times of
need with furniture and food
and things like that, and
these baked beans are going
to go to those people.
I think making YouTube videos
is really fun and we do all
sorts of crazy things that you
get to watch like going into
gold bullion vaults and
rolling Yahtzees and
blowing things up.
-Whoa!
BRADY HARAN: And I don't think
it's that often we think about
the serious things in life and
people who are maybe less
fortunate than us.
This is probably a good time of
year to think about it, and
this is probably also a
good video in which
to think about it.
So under this video, I'm going
to put some links to charities
and things like that that
maybe you want to make a
contribution to.
This year, in particular, my
life, through the people I
work with and also family and
friends, has been affected
quite a lot by cancer.
And I guess cancer research is
something that I think is
really important.
So I've actually set up a
Numberphile page, a JustGiving
page, where you can give money
towards cancer research.
And if that's something that
affects you, or you can't
think of anything but
want to contribute,
that link is below.
I'll include the toilet
charity that Danny
and Emily gave to.
If you send in some suggestions,
maybe I'll try
and include some
others as well.
But it's just something
to think about.
And thanks for all your support
for Numberphile, and
thanks for everyone who
bid on that piece of
paper for the kids.
It was a lot of fun,
and we'll have more
Numberphile videos soon.